The shadowing system in Unreal Engine 5 has been updated to include virtual shadow maps to help deliver consistent higher resolution shadows that work with film quality assets and even enlarge dynamically lit open worlds.
Virtual shadow maps are also built to work seamlessly with Unreal Engine 5's nanite visual geometry, Lumen global illumination and reflections, as well as world partition features.
The images we see on the screen in front of us show us what kind of detail we can get from virtual shadowing.
If we take a look at this image, we'll notice that the shadows on the right hand side look fairly crisp, but let's take a look in the very background of this image as this will really help to highlight the true power that virtual shadow maps give us.
By zooming in on this area and comparing an old version with our previous shadow map technology with the new version, we can see quite a difference in detail.
In the older version, notice there are shadows, but a lot of the detail of the shadows are missing. For example, right here, this should be shadowed.
Instead, we're getting just this little blob right here, which represents the shadowed area.
We're also completely missing shadowing information in this area over here.
Comparing that to using virtual shadow maps, notice the fine detail that we're getting across the entire scene.
There are shadows in places and not only that, but intricate shadow detail throughout this entire area.
And remember, this is representing a very, very small yet scaled up part of the image that you're seeing on the right hand side of the screen.
Finally, the best part about virtual shadow maps is that they are a default feature of Unreal Engine 5, and there is no setting that you need to enable to turn them on.
You just need to simply use the editor and virtual shadow maps will work as intended.